senior political analyst Brit Hume joins
us tonight
Brit you know a couple of things one is
congressman Schiff says that the the
Republicans were holding back or somehow
preventing the Democrat memo from
getting out
they voted last week to start the same
process that the GOP memo had which was
to have all House members view at first
before getting to this vote tonight so
there was a little bit of disingenuous
Innis there about the portrayal of it
well you got to give credit to Adam
Schiff he does a better job of keeping a
straight face and almost in politicians
I've seen in a long time you're
absolutely right Brett the process was
exactly the same
remember the Democrat the Democrats memo
did not exist until after the
Republicans having worked on it for some
time produced their memo and the
Democratic memo was a reaction to it and
of course it was there for some the
process has started somewhat later and
they took them in sequence
remember also read that when the vote
was taken to release the Republican memo
and send it down to the White House for
further review the Democrats all voted
against that tonight it appears from
what Schiff said and what we know that
all the Republicans voted to release the
Democratic memo and send it to the White
House for for a final review so you have
a little bit of study in contrast there
yeah and also Brit it's interesting to
hear him talk about the possible
redaction saying that the White House
may choose to politically redact it
however from what we've been told the
Democrat memo which is a little bit
longer does have some concerns from
Intel officials about sources and
methods as opposed to the GOP memo that
did not deal with that at all and they
really tried to according the
Republicans on that committee avoid any
problems with that well I think that's
right Brett and I think you know it'll
remain to be seen what if any further
reductions are made with it with the
Democratic memo none was made so far as
we know - the Republican memo
and you may recall that mr. Schiff and
others including James Comey Eric Holder
and others were were claiming that there
was a going to be major intelligence
leaks here and damage to our
intelligence sources and methods by
virtue of the Republican moment you'll
notice that you're not hearing those
laments anymore because they obviously
there was nothing in that memo that
would have given rise to that problem so
you have to be you know you have to kind
of keep a scorecard about the claims
that are being made I guess on both
sides about these memos and what they're
gonna do but I think this one from the
Democrats it's well on its way to
release and we'll see to what extent it
successfully knocks down conclusions
that are in the Republican one which is
what we've been trying to do here is to
keep a scorecard on both sides and as
these investigations are going to
different ways to try to keep track of
it all and keep it in perspective Britt
just your thoughts finally on the
fallout from the release of the memo
last week and what we've seen
substantially since then till today well
yeah if you kind of drill down and look
at the essential point in the in the
Republican memo it is that the steel
dossier which was created by and for the
Democratic Party and Hillary Clinton's
campaign we now know from what we
learned today that the Clinton campaign
was involved in feeding information to
mr. steel that this utterly political
document was used as a basis for the
wiretap require tap warrant on a man who
had been advising the Trump campaign
Carter page and you'll notice and and
the and the lip and the the response to
that has been well no we warned the
court of the partisan partisan oranges
our origins however all the defenses of
the behavior by the FBI have not have
not said that the information about the
involvement of the Hillary Clinton
campaign and the Democratic Party was
made known to the judge what we
apparently had here with some vague
references to partisan origins and
that's it I'm not sure that would have
been enough
for a judge you wanted to have all the
information and I suspect it was not
yeah and we'll follow all of this as
always Brett thank you you bet